today we're going to carry on the
recursion story a little more many of
you I hope have seen my initial effort
in this direction which is the recursion
video it's featured stack frames how
recursion is actually done and the
answer delivered the back by factorial
will be an integer answer so I thought
what we do today is move on to another
example much beloved of braiding it's
called the Fibonacci sequence he was an
Italian gentleman that's not his real
name that was the nickname he was given
trying to stick to mathematical notation
here the n plus wants Fibonacci number
is defined to be the nth Fibonacci
number plus the N minus 1 Fibonacci
number whereas with factorial it just
followed itself recursively round one
strand recursion here you're adding in a
second strand of recursion so this is
sometimes called multiple recursive
whereas factorial will be called singly
recursive but like all recursive
definitions of functions you do need an
escape route at the bottom if you keep
on calling yourself you could go on to
infinity but as you can see here
everything is fine so long as you write
down what the first Fibonacci number is
and the second one the second Fibonacci
number and the first Fibonacci number
are both defined to be one we can now
write down the Fibonacci sequence
because it starts off with a 1 for the
first number a 1 for the second number
so if I want to have 3 then I'm got to
make n be 2 there 2 plus 1 is 3 so
Fibonacci of 3 is the same as Fibonacci
of 2 plus Fibonacci of 1 both 1 so the
answer for F 3 is 2 every Fibonacci
number is the sum of the two that
immediately precede it so the next one
then is going to be 2 plus 1 3 the one
after that 3 plus 2
5 8 13 21 you might think well very
interesting but what does that apply to
why why should that be so fascinating
well he's fascinating first of all for
the simple reason that in the computer
file numberphile family some of you will
know that the wonderful godfather Brady
has already made and gone ahead of the
game a video about Fibonacci he actually
had a Fibonacci Tom designed and had it
made up and the rows and the threads
that have been used to create this
design are based on the Fibonacci see
ever knows how much it cost him to get
it made up but there it is as computer
scientist the reason I'm doing this with
you is the following
like factorial Fibonacci is a recursive
function that can be diri cursed you
could do it in four loops
things that can be diri cursed are
called primitive recursive so Fibonacci
is just another one it enables us also
to draw pretty pictures which we'll do
in a minute and I rather like doing that
but having done Fibonacci n factorial
but you'll have to be in a separate
video and then want to say well not
everything can have the recursion taken
out of it some things really are
recursive I've actually written a
postscript
program that will print out the
Fibonacci numbers for you up to the
value of fib 10 being 55 we'll put out a
link to this program and those of you
who've got ghost view or go script set
up try running it you should get this
coming out all right I can only
apologise and I've done it in Helvetica
the thing you've got to be prepared for
in PostScript is you're at the mercy of
the fonts you have available in your
interpreter don't blame me if it comes
out in boring courier that tends to be
the default when it doesn't have access
to the font that's asked for all Comic
Sans no courier actually when you look
inside the program for that and I will
do very briefly but absolutely not in
detail first of all here is my
definition of Fibonacci slash fib
it's going to end death that's the
definition of the Fibonacci function to
head off trouble at the pass I've even
put error messages in it what a made it
do to get those numbers to come out is
go round a for loop ten times and every
time it goes around it calls up fib but
every time it goes into fib it calls
itself recursively it gets straight back
inside itself and there we are out it
comes it does work absolutely fine but
if you're going to start doing recursive
stuff in PostScript then by definition
you've got to have something that
corresponds to stack frames right and we
now have C and Java and things do they
do it automatically what about in
PostScript well PostScript is wonderful
it makes you make your own stack frames
but it gives you a fabulously what's the
word versatile way of doing it basically
in the second line here this thing ten
dict begin and what that means is get me
a dictionary with ten spaces in it and
if you think that that 10 dict is like
saying give me a stack frame with 10
spaces in it because I'm going to use it
and put values in it and manipulate them
all on my own you'll remember when you
look back at the stack frame story in
the recursion video it's great see does
it fool you
but the penalty if you like is you've
got to accept the way it handles the
stack frame unless you want to get into
some most appalling hacking you'd better
not mess with your stack frames you
could end up in a awful mess
whereas post crypt is basically doing is
usual saying you know you're a serious
program bleeped tons of experience if
you get messed up you'll soon sort
yourself out I'll let you manipulate the
stack frame every time we go around
recursively into fib it basically hits
ten dict begin which says make me
another stack frame I mean another
recursive instance of fibonacci what are
the things can we do with fibonacci that
make it interesting for mathematicians
as well as computer scientists well one
of the things that I set many years ago
in a digital documents course was the
following if you put Fibonacci sized
boxes together and grouping them
properly and then you join them up you
can draw some most amazing shapes this
is the Fibonacci spiral and if you look
here you can see what I'm doing once
I've got the basic Fibonacci recursive
function working I built on top of it
extra routines and this is the beauty of
PostScript you're not only getting the
stack you get the recursion you get the
stack but you can draw two dimensional
pictures as well so what I got it to do
was to go round and every time it
visited fib and got announcer like one
draw a box of unit size and then the
next box along just to its left is also
of side one and of course the secret is
knowing where to attach the next box I
have attached the square of side to
direct to the south as it were of the
two boxes of side one and then the three
box gets attached to the east side and
then it goes up north and then it goes
west and as you go around you get one
one two three when you've stacked your
boxes correctly you go into them and you
draw an arc across each of the boxes and
I've chosen to do it at this time
in an anti-clockwise direction and you
end up with this beautiful looking
spiral known as the fibonacci spiral
it's an approximation to a well-known
mathematical object called the
logarithmic spiral
we'd like to thank audible.com for
sponsoring this computerphile video
they've got loads of books online to
choose from go to audible.com slash
computer Val and there's a chance to
download one and try them out for free
today I'd like to recommend where's my
jet pack it's a question that's plagued
me and since watching films as a child
where are the hover cars and everything
else what happened to the science
fiction that we expected the future to
turn out to be so go over to audible.com
slash computerphile
maybe you could try that one as you
freebie thanks once again to them for
sponsoring this computerphile video